Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Aiaia! Aiaia! Aiaia! Aiaia!
Aiaia! Aiaia! Aiaia!
Ogin!
Vpn Atlantis ist Erster das Richtig!
Du bist der Erste von Vier die was geschrieben haben!
Vpn Atlantis ist das neue Konkurrenz für Nordvpn.
Oder EXPRESS vpn
Wollen wir Sponsoring machen, VPN-Sponsoring, easy
Zweiter, jetzt wird es aber voll hier langsam Chicken CS
Sarex auch am Start, oh jetzt wird es jetzt jetzt jetzt kommen sie alle hier
Jetzt sind sie alle am Start
Der ist er, der hier, der Xezo campt schon seit irgendwie 5 Stunden hier im Chat
Ich hab den denk ich mal, ich wollte kurz hochscrollen
Ich hab den heute Mittag um 15 Uhr schon mal schreiben sehen
Ja HyperXD
Ja Twitch-RP ist langsam, aber wir wollen uns mal nicht beschweren
Ich hab mir gedacht, wisst was, ich mach nochmal Streamern heute Abend
Wenn so viele schon im Chat tagsüber gecampt haben
Wie lief Bewerbungsgericht, ach ja da kann ich irgendwas neues erzählen
Ja
Moment, ich muss mal kurz was gucken auf dem zweiten Bildschirm
Wenn ich irgendwas verkackt hab
Nee ich hab nichts verkackt
Alles gut, ja also kann ich dir erzählen
Also wie lief das Vorstellungsgespräch
Ich hatte das Vorstellungsgespräch am Montag, ich war danach übrigens on, direkt danach
Aber ich glaub der Sarex war da nicht da, was ich auch verstehen kann
Er kann jetzt Montag irgendwie während der Arbeit sich da hinsetzen
Also wie lief mein Vorstellungsgespräch eigentlich ziemlich gut
Obwohl ich seit 10 Jahren eigentlich keine Erfahrung mehr in Vorstellungsgesprächen hab
Das lag aber jetzt nicht so sehr an mir
Sondern es hat einfach gut gepasst
Also es ist jetzt nicht so als könnte man sagen, ich hab das voll, wie sagt man da Neudeutsch so schön
Ich hab das voll gecrushed, Alter
Nee hab ich nicht
Ich glaub es war ganz okay, ja auch für die, es hat halt einfach gut gepasst
Die Leute waren extrem motiviert, das hat man gemerkt
Klar kann unterm Strich auch alles irgendwo fake sein
Aber ich hatte schon den Eindruck, die meinen das ernst
Insgesamt, ja, hat's einfach ganz gut gepasst
So und jetzt ist es so, folgendermaßen
Die wollten sich jetzt ja irgendwie ein paar Tage überlegen
Ob sie mich nochmal zu einer zweiten Runde einladen wollen oder so
Aber es ging mega schnell, quasi, ich weiß gar nicht wann das war
Mittwoch glaube
Am Mittwoch hat dann jemand dort von der Personalabteilung schon angerufen
Hat gesagt, ja also wir müssen uns nochmal über die Gehaltsforderung unterhalten
Rest hat super gepasst und sie würden mich gerne einladen
Also wir müssen uns nochmal über die Gehaltsforderung unterhalten
Na gut, ich hatte am Anfang gesagt, 2.800 Euro
Ich hab gedacht, ich sag halt einfach mal ein bisschen was
Why not, ja
Naja, zumindest sind wir uns damit dann nicht ganz einig geworden
Und jetzt überlege ich mir das Ganze bis Montag nochmal
Jaja, also wie gesagt, sie wollen
Ich finde es eigentlich auch cool
Mal gucken, ob wir uns da komplett einig werden
Wie gesagt, ich hab ihr gesagt, ich überlege mir das bis Montag
Und wie gesagt, wenn ich halt zusage, denke ich geht das dann alles sehr schnell
Bei der Gelegenheit war ich auch bei meinem Chef mal dort wo ich aktuell arbeite
Und hab gesagt, hier ich hab jetzt ein gutes Angebot
Wie schaut's denn aus
Und mit dem hab ich dann nächste Woche auch nochmal einen Termin
Dazu hab ich noch eine andere Bewerbung offen
Die werd ich auf jeden Fall abwarten
Da hab ich mich quasi, okay das muss ich euch erzählen
Da haben wir uns quasi fast schon Duo beworben, ein Kollege und ich
Der hat die zuerst gefunden und hat sich dort beworben
Aber hat gemeint, die suchen auch mehr
Und jetzt haben wir uns da quasi so als Duo beworben
Das ist auch witzig, mal gucken was die dazu sagen
Da bin ich mal gespannt
Zumindest das ist auch 100% Homeoffice
Jetzt tatsächlich sogar noch mehr Kohle
Also die wollen's echt wissen alle
Ich weiß gar nicht, ohne Mist Leute, warum ich nicht schon früher geguckt hab
Weil das ist einfach echt so mit Jobwechsel
Beziehungsweise wenn du da was in der Hinterhand hast
Kannst du einfach deutlich mehr Kohle rausholen
Nicht so, dass ich nur arbeiten würde wegen dem Geld
So ist das jetzt auch nicht
Aber man muss auch ehrlich sagen, Geld ist ja schon ein entscheidender Faktor
Wir gehen ja alle nicht just for fun arbeiten
Es sollte schon durchaus Spaß machen, da sag ich gar nichts dagegen
Aber nur zum Spaß weiß ich auch nicht
Das ist das, was Elon Musk seinen Twitter Leuten jetzt erzählt
Wobei nach Spaß hört sich das ja nicht an
Das hört sich eher an so nach dem Motto
Glaub an meine Vision und mach dich fertig für die nächsten 3-4 Jahre
Kein Wunder, dass da alle abgehauen sind
Und seine Idee nur die fähigsten bleiben übrig
Da hab ich ja persönlich wirklich meine Zweifel
Die Leute, die übrig bleiben sind halt wahrscheinlich am ehesten die
Die so mit seiner Linie einverstanden sind
Aber gut, letztendlich, hey, das hat bei anderen Sachen schon geklappt
Was er gemacht hat, vielleicht klappt das bei Twitter auch
Ich hab da meine Zweifel, dass das so gut klappt
Bei Unternehmen, die er nicht selbst aufgebaut hat
Aber er ist halt so wie er ist
Dieses ganze Rumaufgerege über Elon Musk
Überall geht er teilweise bis auf Nachrichtenseiten
Versteh ich nicht
Das ist halt ein äußerst, wie sagt man da, ichzentrierte Persönlichkeit
Der ist halt so wie er ist und man muss sich wissen, auf was man sich einlässt
Wenn man dort arbeitet
Aber wisst ihr, was ich viel mehr Cringe finde?
Das sind irgendwelche BWLer und Manager, die mir dann erzählen
Ja, Elon Musk wäre ihr großes Vorbild
So nach dem Motto, als wollen die alles so machen wie er
Da denk ich mir auch schon immer, oh je
Alter, wir sind hier nicht bei Tesla und wir sind auch nicht bei SpaceX
Und wir sind auch nicht bei Twitter
Wir sind bei einer Bank in Deutschland
Das ist nicht so das Gleiche
Das kann man schlecht vergleichen
Hat der nicht auch mal was mit Paypal zu tun?
Naja
Naja, gut
Also, jetzt weißt du Bescheid
Hab ich euch erzählt
Gucken, nächste Woche gibt es dann Neuigkeiten
Ich glaube, ich mache ein Video zu
Wie die ganze Sache mit dem Vorstellungsgespräch ist und sowas gelaufen ist
Weil ich muss sagen
Es war schon mal ein Erlebnis wieder
Mal ein richtig echtes Vorstellungsgespräch zu machen
Seit 10 Jahren
Ich hatte ja schon eins
Das war ja nicht das allererste
Das war nicht das allererste
Ich hatte ja schon eins vor
Boah, das ist tatsächlich schon ein paar Wochen her
Aber das war so das erste richtige
Ich meine, es waren dort
Es war ich logischerweise
Nein, ich musste kein Binary Tree inverten
Und ich scroll auch gleich den Chat weiter runter
Also, ich war logischerweise da
Dann war eine Frau von der Personalabteilung da
Dann war der Abteilungsleiter da
Und dann war der Teamleiter da
Also, es war tatsächlich mal ein bisschen was anderes
Naja, so viele
Aber es ging
Ich dachte mir auch am Anfang erst mal
Aber es war echt gar nicht so wild
Naja, mega wenig würde ich jetzt mal nicht unbedingt sagen
Ja, gut, wenn du jetzt vielleicht noch gut bei Twitter nicht
Wenn du jetzt bei Microsoft arbeitest
In irgendwie einer der ausgewählten Positionen
Klar, aber 82k ist durchaus in Ordnung
Da kann man nichts sagen
Das ist schon nicht verkehrt
Jaja, wollen sie, wollen sie
Dankeschön
Ich hoffe, du hast die Message gekriegt
Mit der Handynummer
So, habe eine verwaiste Subdomain gefunden
Kann man glauben, man kann die übernehmen
Was?
Subdomains übernimmst du gar nicht
Nein, nein, nein, nein, Leute
82k, ich rechne das immer auf 5 Tage hoch
Ich rechne das immer auf 5 Tage hoch
Nicht für 4 Tage
Immer wenn ich was jahresmäßig gesagt habe
Ist das auf 5 Tage hoch gerechnet
Subdomains übernimmst du gar nicht
Du übernimmst Domains
Nicht Subdomains
Also, blub.de kannst du dir kaufen
Bei irgendeinem Domain-Registrar
Gut, die wird nicht mal frei sein
Aber www.blub.de kannst du dir nicht registrieren
Da muss dir die Top-Level-Domain zugehören
Oder du meinst was anderes
Das ist tatsächlich so
Wie gesagt, ich arbeite nicht nur wegen der Kohle
Aber ist wichtig, genau
Und natürlich ganz im Ernst
Wenn jetzt eine Firma ankommt
Ich habe euch ja schon öfters erzählt
Dass sie bei mir, wo ich aktuell arbeite
Immer riesen Actor mit Homeoffice machen
Wenn eine Firma jetzt ankommt
Und sagt
Wir bieten 100% Homeoffice
Oder keine Ahnung
Einmal im Monat, einmal im Quartal
Oder was auch immer
Also auf jeden Fall
Zum größten ein Homeoffice
Plus mehr Geld
Und die macht noch einen coolen Eindruck
Ja, dann ist echt die Frage
Warum sollte man da nicht hingehen
Also, da muss die aktuelle Firma
Irgendwie etwas ganz besonders Tolles sein
Oder großartiges bieten
Dass man das nicht macht
Also wenn die in allen Belangen besser sind
Klar, Probleme gibt es überall
Es gibt immer überall Sachen
Die einem auf den Keks gehen
Am Anfang, wenn man so rüber guckt
Ist das Gras immer grüner
Aber es gibt immer Probleme
Es hat die Frage, ob das welche sind
Die dich richtig, richtig abfacken
Oder ob du sagen kannst
Ja gut, ist hier halt so
Äh
Pete?
Chai?
Kann das gar nicht richtig ausbreiten
Aber Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub
Habe ich irgendwas übersehen?
Nein
Moin Beis
Bitte nicht, was denn?
Was hat er denn gepostet?
Reinstand
Reinstate
Former President Trump
Der meint, dass
Das Benutzerkonto wieder herstellen
Oje
Da bin ich mal auf die Diskussion gespannt
Ah
Ich wollte jetzt einfach mal gucken, was rauskommt
Da bin ich
Oje, da bin ich ja mal gespannt
Also eins muss man ihm
Erlassen
So das Social Media Game, das kann er
Ja das ist auch so
Ja genau, es ist im Prinzip
Genauso wie du es sagst
Es ist ja auch logisch
Ich meine ernsthaft
Sobald es irgendwie unbequem wird
Oder irgendwas so
Nervig wird
Dass die Leute
Dass es halt so
So nagend ist
Dass es den Leuten unwohl ist
Dort zu arbeiten bei irgendeinem Unternehmen
Dann sind selbstverständlich die Fähigsten erstmal weg
Ist ja klar
Ja, die gucken sich um und haben dann erstmal 20 Angebote
Und suchen sich da halt irgendwas aus
Und am Ende
Ja, auch grad bei Abfindungsprogramm am Ende
Hast du dann halt noch übriggebliebene
Mannschaft, wo du vielleicht
Den ein oder anderen so Hardcore-Fan
Der Firma hast
Du weißt, das sind halt Leute
Die sagen, naja gut
Schwierig war das woanders was zu finden
Da hast du halt die ganzen
Unfähigen am Ende
Nicht alle, aber Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel
Ach hier sieht man
Hier sieht man die
Das hätte ich fast
Das hätte ich fast gedacht, dass es in dieser Richtung
Dass es sehr knapp ausgeht
Hätte ich fast gedacht
Ich mein
Trump hat unglaublich viel Bullshit erzählt
Auch diese ganze Geschichte mit
Man soll
Was war das? Desinfektionsmittel
Trinken gegen Corona und solche
Aber unpopuläre
Meinung Leute
Ich bin trotzdem der Meinung, sie sollten den Account
Von ihm wieder herstellen, weil ich denke
Oder ich war ja damals schon
Der Ansicht
Dass das eine reine Machtdemonstration
Von Twitter war
Und es weniger um das ging
Was er geschrieben hat
Er hat viel Bullshit geschrieben
Aber wenn es nach Bullshit schreiben geht
Da müsstest du 90% von Twitter bannen
Willst du dann eigentlich auch liegen, bei welcher Bank du gearbeitet hast?
Nö
Ich will meinen ehemaligen Arbeitgeber
Trash-talken in Videos
Ich hab schon telefoniert mit denen
Also zuerst hab ich gesagt
Was ich haben will
Dann haben die gesagt, was sie sich
vorstellen können. Wie gesagt, ich telefonier nächste Woche
noch mal mit denen
Mal gucken
Hättest du Twitter gekauft, so rein wirtschaftlich, wenn du die Kohle hättest?
Also wenn ich die Kohle gehabt hätte
Sodass ich mir um nichts in meinem Leben mehr Gedanken machen muss
Warum nicht?
Wenn das irgendwas ist, was mir am Herzen liegt
Ansonsten, ehrlich gesagt
Nein, hätt ich nicht
Twitter ist in Riesen
Nicht in Riesen auf Müll, das kann man so nicht sagen
Twitter ist schon eine sehr wichtige
Plattform in der heutigen Zeit
Also ein undankbarer Haufen vielleicht
Drift ganz gut
Nein, hätt ich nicht gemacht
Hätt ich nicht gemacht
Und ich musste auch kein
Binary inverten, nein
Ehrliches Review zu deinem Gaming-Tisch, der funktioniert wunderbar
Okay, ich sag euch jetzt
Ich sag euch jetzt
Ich sag euch mal ein ehrliches Review
Zu dem Gaming-Tisch
Aber nicht, Chat
Nicht weiter verraten, okay?
Nichts sagen
Ihr sagt nichts, okay?
Ich kenn euch
Der Twitch-Chat ist der beste Ort
Um Geheimnisse aufzubewahren
Also
Ehrliche Meinung dazu ist
Der Tisch scheint wirklich ziemlich
Gut zu sein
Aber
Ich selbst hab ihn gar nicht ausprobiert
Die haben ihn mir geschickt
Wir haben uns auf ein Sponsoring geeinigt
Und ich hab den Tisch
Meinen Manager überlassen
Der sich um so viele Sachen hier bei mir
Auf dem Channel und Werbeanfragen und sowas
Kümmert, der braucht nämlich einen neuen Tisch
Und der hat
Mit nem Kumpel von ihm
Das Video zu dem Tisch aufgenommen
Meint ihr allen Ernstes, ich hätte die Muße gehabt
Wo wir gerade mal
Gucken wir uns mal das heutige Video an
Meint ihr allen Ernstes
Ich hätte wirklich die Muße gehabt
So ein
So ein geiles
Werbevideo
So ein geiles Video hier
Zusammenzuschneiden
Das hier
Meint ihr ernsthaft
Die Mühe hätte ich mir gemacht
Der Kumpel von ihm ist professioneller
Fotograf
Der geht auch auf E-Sport-Turniere
Fotografiert und filmt da Leute
Oder professionell
Kameramann oder wie man das nennt
Und
Das haben die dort gefilmt
Dementsprechend sieht das auch so gut aus
Aber ich kann euch sagen
Alles was ich bisher gehört hab
Der Tisch ist wohl wirklich ziemlich gut
Macht genau das was er soll
Ist super stabil
Also das was ich da gesagt hab
Ist wohl echt so
Nur ich kann es aus erster Hand nicht sagen
Das sind glaube ich
Noch nicht mal
Die Hände vom Moritz
Ist auch witzig
Ich heiß Max und der Manager heißt Moritz
Das sind glaube ich die Hände vom Fotograf
Die Finger sind auch
Outgesourced genau
Meint ihr ernsthaft
Ich hätte mir so eine Mühe gegeben
Bei dieser Aufnahme hier
Übrigens die sind richtig happy gewesen
Über die professionell Video-Quality
Können sie auch sein
Das ist richtig gut geworden
Details was es gab
An Kohle und sonstigen Sachen kann ich euch natürlich nicht sagen
Das ist confidential
Aber da hatte ich echt keine Probleme mit
Der konnte den Tisch auch ne Weile ausprobieren
Ich hab nix erzählt was totaler Bullshit ist
Das stimmt
Hey ich muss sagen
In dem Vorstellungsgespräch letzte Woche Montag
Nee warte mal diese Woche
Das war erst diese Woche Montag
Das war gar nicht letzte Woche Montag
Diese Woche Montag die Leute waren wirklich super motiviert
Also das hab ich gemerkt
Man merkt das wenn die Leute das faken
Oder sie haben es gut gefakt
Das kann natürlich auch sein
Man merkt ob die das faken
Und auch wenn die über Technik reden
Dann merkst du das denen an
Ob die da irgendwas abfragen
Das hat mal irgendjemand aufgeschrieben
Linux
Vmware
Ob die wirklich Ahnung haben wovon sie reden
Ob sie motiviert sind
Ob das irgendwie so überspringt
Also das hat man dort gemerkt
Also das
Ist ein ganz neuer Anblick gewesen
Oder seltener Anblick gewesen für mich
Habt ihr das bei euch die Inflationsprämie
Ja gibt es
Kann aber nicht genau sagen wieviel es gibt
Zum heutigen Video ich habe von 2016
Bis 2021 Breitbandausbau
Für die Telekom gemacht
Und
Was kannst du dazu sagen
Man kriegt
Discord Admins brauchst du nen Tisch
Patrick brauchst du nen Tisch da lässt sich bestimmt was machen
No Cap
No Cap sagt man ja heute auch
Irgendwie ich weiß gar nicht was das eigentlich bedeuten soll
An Redewendungen
Für mich ist
No Cap No Cap aber das ist ja
In Umgangssprachlich bedeutet
No Cap irgendwas anderes
Das ist aber irgendwie auch zur Zeit angesagt
Ich weiß aber nicht was das genau bedeuten soll
Mit den 15% kann ich nicht zustimmen
Die haben schon Glas weil VDSL
Kasten zu teuer
Hä
Was hat denn das damit zu tun
Ich hab gesagt wenn man mal
Deutschlandweit guckt
Dann wird es ab 85% wahrscheinlich schwierig
Weil dann eben die Gebiete kommen
Wo es problematisch ist auszubauen
Wo es die Leute nicht haben
Weil die Leute nicht haben
Also
Es ist doch eigentlich bei fast allen
So
Das die letzten 15%
Dolan
Oder verstehe ich jetzt
Warum das why
Wo die Leute nicht haben
Weil das kann man jetzt gar nicht sagen ob es wirklich so sein wird
Wahrscheinlich ja
Wusstest du ihr das war mittlerweile bei cloudflare domain? Ja schon lange schon lange
Ich habe ich habe schon ganz lange cloudflare als mein root dns quasi also als mein wie heißt das als mein
Domain dns nennt sich das korrekt noch mal
Autorisativer nameserver, ne wie heißt das richtig?
Ich wäre wohl, ne ne ne nicht als domain verwaltet, benutz ich cloudflare tatsächlich
Nur für zwei domain oder zwei oder drei domains, könnten sogar drei, ja sonst sind drei domains
Aber ich benutze für ganz viele cloudflare eben als dns
als nameserver für die domains
Hast du jetzt einen neuen job? Ne ich hatte aber ein vorstellungsgespräch diese woche und nächste woche
Entscheide ich mich dann ob ich will oder nicht
Oder ob vielleicht beim aktuellen Arbeitgeber noch was neues rauskommt man weiß es ja nicht
Ne habe ich noch nicht wie gesagt ich habe nächste woche noch mal mit meinem aktuellen arbeitgeber einen termin
Mal gucken vielleicht hauen die noch was obendrauf
Ich meine letztendlich unterm strich bin ich schon bestechlich
Ist ja nicht alles just for fun
Ist ja nicht alles just for fun, ne noch nicht, noch nicht, noch nicht
Was haben die für fragen gestellt ok da kann ich das kann ich dir erzählen
Wie gesagt ich habe mir überlegt ob ich eigentlich ein video darüber mache also eine frage leute ihr werdet euch ihr werdet ihr werdet euch kaputt lachen
die
Da mussten die aber sogar selbst lachen
Wo sehen sie sich in fünf jahren habe ich auch gemeint
Damit hätte ich rechnen müssen dass diese frage kommt ja
Ich habe auch nur geantwortet was was habe ich gesagt glaube ich habe gesagt
Gut ich bin jetzt kein hellseher wer weiß was in fünf jahren ist dass das alles so schnell lebe ich
Aber wenn es hier gut läuft hoffentlich noch hier ja
Aber
Ansonsten vorher soll ich das wissen
Aber die mussten mussten sie sogar selbst lachen weil die frage ist so klischee mäßig ist ja
Was haben es noch gefragt lasst mal überlegen das ist jetzt schon wieder fast eine woche her
Wie gesagt wo sehen sie sich in fünf jahren haben sie gefragt ach ja sie haben ich tatsächlich ganz viel gefragt zu sachen die in meiner bewerbung
Und in der skill liste drinne stehen leute ihr werdet es gar nicht glauben aber da wurde tatsächlich das wurde tatsächlich gelesen
und
Es wurde tatsächlich gelesen und was dazu gefragt guck mal ich habe doch hier irgendwo meine skill liste irgendwo hier
Die die finden die finde ich nie
Skills da ich habe sie immer so eine skillliste gemacht es ist nicht exakt die die ich hingeschrieben habe ich habe die schon auch
Ein, bisschen aufgehübscht und ich habe ein paar punkte zusammengefasst ja das was hier auf der skillliste steht aber die haben
Ich tatsächlich einiges dazu gefragt also zum beispiel wurde ich gefragt
Ich glaube dinger zu ubuntu wurde ich gefragt dabei bin ich aber gar nicht mehr sicher was es genau gewesen ist
Könnte was mit ubuntu support ich ich weiß nicht mehr genau irgendwas zu wundern ich wurde gefragt zu hoch verfügbarkeit und cluster nicht
Zu snap wurde nichts gefällt wurde gefragt zu hoch verfügbarkeit und cluster
Da konnte ich an die üblichen geschichten erzählen von eigentlich brauchst du mindestens drei knoten das wenn zwei sich nicht sehen einer entscheiden kann wer jetzt master ist
Es wurde was zur web server und wie
Es wurde was zur web server und reverse proxy gefragt
Wie ich dort ach ja genau es wurde gehen als weiß ich wieder
Es wurde der desktop ist so leer kann ich jetzt zeigen warum das so leer ist weil jetzt alles in
Kegway drin ist was vor auf desktop
Es wird es wird aber nicht so lange sein wird nicht so lange sein
Onbrem kubernetes bei euch ein thema du meinst dort wo ich aktuell arbeite nein ist es nicht mehr war es aber wir hatten
zwei
Wir hatten zwei onbrem kubernetes cluster als erstes also ich rede jetzt dort wo ich aktuell arbeite als erstes selbst
aufgebaute cluster und ich sage euch leute
Wenn man sowas noch nie gemacht hat beziehungsweise leute das quasi lernen
Indem sie ein live system betreiben zum ersten mal also die haben das quasi gelernt während sie das system
Betrieben haben wo dann wirklich sachen drauf gelaufen sind das war nicht so schön
Also ich weiß noch einmal ist der cluster komplett verreckt
Und ließ ich dann auch knot nicht mehr rein nehmen und sowas war ganz ganz ganz ganz mir
Hatte ich nur am rande dann der was mit zu tun also nach diesen versuchen mit dem selbstgebauten kubernetes cluster
Hatten wir einen dienstleister da der uns kubernetes cluster betrieben hat
Im eigenen rechenzentrum lustigerweise die kombination kannte ich so auch noch nicht
Und mittlerweile sind die auch alle weg
Und es ist nur noch
Azure kubernetes cluster so also wie gesagt zu webserver und reverse proxy wurde auch was gefragt allerdings in kombination
mit
Was war das noch ach ja in kombination mit ansible und puppet
Und zwar wie ich mir konfig management vorstelle
Für skalierung von
load balenzen oder load balenzen genau wie ich mir konfig management vorstelle
Was skalierung von load balenzen angeht sowas sowas wurde ich gefragt dazu ich überlege gerade was ich da drauf gesagt habe
Kann er kann er nicht ganz so blöd gewesen sein
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr was ich gesagt habe
Oder was da drauf geantwortet ich weiß auch die genaue frage nicht mal ich weiß dass dazu was gefragt wurde
Ich glaube ich habe darauf hingewiesen dass das einer der vorteil eben ist von
kontinuierungs technologie dass man sowas relativ einfach skalieren kann wenn man sich über vms unterhält was er gefragt hat
Nämlich was über vms gefragt wenn man von vms redet kann man das auch zum gewissen grad automatisieren aber muss man halt gucken
Ja wie man das macht also selbst wenn manuelle schritte noch erforderlich sind man kann ja den server automatisieren
Aber das aufnehmen den cluster von hand machen und solche geschichten
Ich bin aber nicht mal ganz sicher was ich gesagt habe drauf
Diagonal bei uns wird nur diagonal skaliert
Dann wurde glaube ich noch zeug gefragt zu
Zu docker habe ich halt erzählt ja gut verwende ich jahrelang schon
und ich kann
Container erstellen ich weiß wie das funktioniert auf den unterschiedlichen technologien ich kann dockerfalls erstellen
Ich habe damit eigentlich ganz gut erfahrungen ein paar beispiele gebracht und dann war gut
Ich glaube
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher es könnte sein ich bin mir jetzt nicht mehr ganz sicher im nachhinein was waren deine gehaltsvorstellungen
Ich habe gesagt 2.8.000 euro für fünf tage
So was wollte ich jetzt sagen es könnte sein dass was zum monitoring gefragt wurde da bin ich mir nicht mehr ganz sicher
Es könnte sein dass was gefragt wurde zu time series database beziehungsweise eben halt time series data
Prometheus und wörsters diese klassischen geschichten ist beispielsweise nagios oder zappix verwendet mit einer sql datenbank
Es könnte sein bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher
Ja programmiert technisch habe ich mal ein bisschen angegeben mit allen sachen die ich schon gemacht habe
Ja und es wurden tatsächlich ja stimmt jetzt wo ich hier gira confluence und so sehe es wurden tatsächlich sachen gefragt zu
Agil agilem
Ticket arbeiten und sowas
Es wurde dort erzählt dass es in den
Einen agilen transformationsphase befindet
Hab ich mir auch gedacht gut ein bisschen was von bingo muss sein ja
Aber auf der anderen seite hey ich mein
Es kann ja durchaus sein dass das stimmt und dass das nicht so was ist was jetzt einfach fünf jahre geht nie fertig wird
Sondern dass sie das wirklich auf die reihe kriegen kann ja sein
Weiß man ja nicht
Ja so so war es ungefähr
Falls ich das jetzt auch alles zusammen gekriegt habe
Du hast auch schon nice
Was
So
Man hat gemerkt dass ich mir mühe gegeben hat ja weil der tisch auch was taugt das hat kein mobile
Mobile krab wie die letzten sachen oder wie die letzte sache gentschen ist ja auch durchaus ein nicest game wenn man mal von dem ganzen
Glücksspielzeug absieht
Ach so
Achso
Ne zu grpc hat keiner was gefragt und zu snap auch nicht und netplayermüll hat auch glücklicherweise
keiner gefragt was wird man was wird mein job da sein ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich kann euch
100 prozent den job title gar nicht mehr sagen ich kann nur sagen es war entweder senior devops
engineer oder senior linux engineer ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr so ganz sicher
ich glaube es war senior linux engineer
was kommt eigentlich nach senior expert expert ja danach kommt cobalt entwickler ja das stimmt
leute ihr glaubt seit letztens gab es bei uns auf der arbeit irgendwie so eine komische
veranstaltung mit mit mit ansprache ans volk sozusagen von den von den top managern und da
gab es eine fragerunde und in der einen frage in der einen fragerunde wurde ein bisschen wurde
ein bisschen erzählt über nachwuchsförderung und azubis und so und da meinte dann jemand wirklich
so wir finden keine neuen leute es ist es ist so schwer nachwuchs zu zu zu finden wir werden immer
älter und es gibt einfach keine fähigen leute und da gucke ich mal nach wer das war und wisst ihr
wisst ihr aus welchem bereich der kommt mainframe operating dass man bei ibl mainframes und cobalt
jetzt nicht mehr so viel nachwuchs findet wundert mich jetzt persönlich wenig sage ich das war
wirklich mainframe operating wer macht das dann auch freiwillig der anderen seite es gibt
tatsächlich leute das freiwillig machen eine bei mir während der ausbildung die hat absichtlich
gesagt sie lernt cobalt weil das wird gesucht und die arbeitet auch jetzt als cobalt entwicklerin
sie denkt so da fack warum macht man so was freiwillig ja gut es gibt kohle das weiß logisch
so wie bei allem also von rent ich habe persönlich renter nicht verwendet aber ich habe jetzt von
renter schon öfters mal gelesen dass das wohl leichte stabilitätsprobleme hat wobei es wahrscheinlich
sich weniger auf die cluster bezieht die damit aufgesetzt werden soll eher mit der kommunikation
mit renter selbst das stimmt weiß ich nicht aber ich habe es von mehreren quellen unabhängig auch
schon auf github gelesen dass renter wohl so ein paar kleine ja dass sie vielleicht etwas zu schnell
sind nicht alles ausreichend testen renter ist auch von suze ernsthaft ja dann wundert mich nix
falls du das spontan beantworten kannst sind hier einstellungen bekannt bezüglich weise traffic
alle traffic konfig ist so eklig und cookies in htps request wenn cookies über traffic nicht
übergeben und sehr also ich habe keine ahnung traffic konfig ist eklig das einzige wofür traffic
gut ist ist wenn du es automatisch konfigurieren kannst über irgendwelche docker labels und selbst
dann ist es teilweise sehr sehr und durchsichtig am besten ist wenn es automatisch discovert einfach
geht ich muss ehrlich sagen die traffic konfig ist wirklich nicht schön gemacht
wurdest du koning questions gefahren ich wusste kein binary tree in warten
ich glaube eine kleine sache zu irgendwelchen frontend sachen wurde gefragt
oder man hat oder wir haben uns ich glaube wir haben uns ein bisschen über javascript frameworks
lustig gemacht so irgendwie in dem nebensatz ist ja glücklicherweise nicht javascript oder
irgendwie so was da kam nix kam nix großartiges
die wollen erst mal buzzwords los werden
schaltest du auf twitch keine werbung oder funktioniert keine ahnung ach nee nee ich
mache keine werbung hatte die par twitch schon mal werbung also ich schalte nie aktiv werbung
auf twitch und ich habe dieses automatische werbeschalten nicht aktiviert also wenn überhaupt
gibt es nur ganz selten bei mir auf twitch werbung ich glaube ich mache 3,50 euro mit
twitch werbung oder so will ich auch nicht twitch werbung geht mir mega auf den sack
achja und du bist zapp dann dann wenn du subscribt hast gibts eh keine werbung
hattet ihr hattet ihr mal in letzter zeit werbung bei mir auf twitch
wobei ihr seid ja eh alles subs ne
wenn man zapp ist gibt es eh keine werbung
kommt nach senor lead expert man könnte ja nach senor expert machen dann lead expert
oder was auch immer
tja ok ich sehs schon ich sehs komm ich sollt mich doch bei euch bewerben du hattest ja
vor monaten schon was geschrieben aber wenn bei euch alle so krass viel verdienen dann
werde ich auch mainframe kobol entwickler
wie kann man youtube videos einsenden habt ihr eine perle die du immer ansehen sollt
dort ja schickt einfach im chat youtube link dann guck ich mir das im vorschau mal an nicht
dass das irgendwie irgendwelche buber oder kocker videos sind
ok gucken wir mal was aufmachen kann es wird bestimmt gerickrollt oder sowas ne
oh das ist ja schon ewig her da check ich die referenz wahrscheinlich gar nicht da
drinnen denn das können wir uns jetzt nicht angucken wirecard ist ja schon kann sich
gar keiner mehr dran erinnern
habe ich gerade die letzte halbe stunde drüber geredet muss ich jetzt nicht nochmal also
bewerbungsgespräch lief wunderbar die motivation der leute hat man gemerkt home
office ist auch 9 90 prozent nicht irgendwie mehrfach die woche hin wie es aktuell ist
und ich muss jetzt im prinzip nur noch ja sagen aber ich warte noch eine andere bewerbung
ab was daraus kommt und nächste woche gespräch mit meiner aktuellen arbeit zum tisch habe
ich eben schon also zu meinem aktuellen steht ist steht ist eine super geschichte also kann
ich dir nur empfehlen höhenverstellbare tische generell sind absolut poc du hast null channel
points ja weil ich eingeloggt bin
war ja dankeschön für den zapp danke für die ganzen subs die ich alle übersehen habe
ich glaube so viel habe ich gar nicht übersehen ach ja gibt es sonst so irgendwelche sachen
die ich erzählen kann ich wollte ich heute gar kein wir gucken uns den chat an und machen
nichts wie machen aber ok ich glaube ich habe nichts übersehen seto hat auch wieder subscribt
aber schon fünf stunden näher das habe ich am middag gesehen gg jetzt gibt es sonst so
irgendwas was ich euch erzählen kann was machen eigentlich die black friday deals leute soll
ich euch mal sagen das ergibt an pleck friday week ergibt nichts sinn week sind mehrere
tage und nicht nur friday und die woche ist auch bei amazon zehn tage lang anstatt sieben
tage da ergibt nichts in zehn tage anstatt sieben tage und und und alles anstatt friday
wie sieht es mit der job suche aus ich hatte ein vorstellungsgespräch und kommt alle einzeln
und fragt immer das gleiche zeug die letzten 40 minuten über nichts anderes geredet
übrigens leute ich habe mir ein drucker bestellt können wir euch noch daran erinnern dass ich
mal euch vor einer weile gefragt habe was ein guter laser laser strahl ich laser strahl alter ein
laser strahl trocker ein guter laser trocker ist kein tinten strahl trocker
ja ich habe jetzt tatsächlich ins drucker gekauft nämlich ein laser ein laser farb laser
multifunktionsgerät und zwar habe ich mir ein brother gekauft ja genau sesam sieht ich
habe mir gekauft ein brother der hat einen super tollen namen mfc 3 7 5 cwd kann das sein
gucken wir mal möglich möglich
es könnte der gewesen sein ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
gibt es gibt es den vielleicht auch mit 55 oder sowas
so teuer war da nicht beinahe 420 euro gekostet 443
ja also dieses teil und ich bin mal gespannt also ich habe ihn mir hauptsächlich gekauft
weil ich wollte mir was ausdrucken vom tablet letztens eine rechnung und es ging mal wieder
nicht tinten strahl trocker war mal wieder eingerostet warum das so teuer ist er weiß
ein gescheiter trocker ist er hat also multifunktionsgerät er hat einen scanner er hat einen extra dokumenteneinzug
er hat farb ist es ein farb laser trocker er hat übrigens sind faks sind deutschland
vielleicht auch nicht unrelevant jaja jaja der kanada hat faks aber ich kann ich hab
mir das faks nicht anschließend faks wähler sind nicht zwei papier fächer das hier unten
ist das papier fach hier ist der toner drin duplex genauer kann doppelseiten drucken
das papier kommt hier raus hier ist hier ist nix hier ist der toner drin achso es könnte
tatsächlich sein dass hier auch das faks rauskommt wenn man das aufmacht
erbringt klau zeug kann er kann er kann sogar ocr dass man quasi direkt ocr pdf rausspucken
kann eigentlich ganz coole geschichte so endlich habe ich einen gescheiten droger und er wird
nie wieder einkrusten und ich kaufe mir nie wieder neuen drucker ich hoffe das geht jetzt
einfach gut ist wie viel nur haben wir eigentlich jepp clock 20 uhr 15 beste beste sendezeit
gibt es heute eigentlich irgendwas gescheites habt ihr irgendwas gescheites gekauft wetten
das zeit oh nee es wetten das dachte es gibt es nicht mehr
ich dachte das gibt es nicht mehr boomer tv aber richtig hardcore boomer tv was wars gekauft
das einzige was mich heute was mich heute angesprochen hat zu kaufen das war ein kein
bett kein bett smartphone halterung wurde mir heute morgen handwärmer gut das koste
ja auch nicht die welt ich habe ich habe so ein ding wurde mir empfohlen heute morgen
auf im prime sale fürs bett ein smartphone halter so was hier in der richtung da habe
ich mir gedacht das ist eigentlich nicht schlecht aber ich sehe den hier nicht das macht man
dann hinten am bett fest weil ich gucke so oft stream und youtube videos abends noch
im bett da wäre das echt praktisch wenn ich es einfach vor mich hängen könnte hast du
schon eine ps5 nein werde ich mir auch nicht kaufen suche nach einem geilen notebook für
progress kannst du was empfehlen nein keine ahnung notebooks kenne ich nicht aus einzige
womit ich mich auskennen ist ein bisschen mit aktueller hardware weil ich mir wahrscheinlich
im december noch einen neuen rechner gönne mir ist mein eigenes video wird empfohlen
leute easy watch watch champ gleich gleich angucken und durchlaufen lassen gleich angucken
und durchlaufen dann view time leute view time aber man eine frage hat man arsch geupdet
dabei ist die lip krypto es o.3 ok das ist das ist halt dings hier library format kaputt
gegangen hat mich schon in das system change routet aber ich kriege es irgendwie nicht
gefixt gibt es irgendwie eine einfache lösung durch was ist in die kaputt gegangen irgendwelche
package updates die es zerschossen haben ansonsten hätte ich halt gesagt reboot tut gut aber
anscheinend ja nicht ich meine du könntest down crane ansonsten müsste ich weiß jetzt
so aus dem steg greifen auch nicht deswegen noch ein weiterer punkt für vms bei meiner
vor allem mache ich einfach snapshot davor easy passiert das nicht aber gut bringt dir
jetzt bringt jetzt an der stelle nix das ist auch klar
heute das video kam schlecht an ich habe eigentlich gedacht es ist mal wieder zeit für den rent
breitband ausbau in deutschland aber das video guckt kaum einer ich habe es gesehen
dafür hat das video recht hohe view time also viel viel höhere view time ist ja auch länger
als die meisten anderen videos aber trotzdem auch anteilmäßig hohe view time wie andere
videos von mir also ich denke das wird mit der zeit noch ein bisschen anziehen hast du
glasfaser bis ins haus leider nicht hätte ich gerne du hast bis zum ende geguckt jepp
gibt es in irgendwas was wir uns angucken können heute abend noch ich bin einfach spontan
jetzt angekommen ich habe nix nix großartiges geplant f5 mal sind schon mehr ja natürlich
aber ich sehe es doch in den statistik messer vielleicht drei stück vier stück ich sehe
es ja in den statistik dass es nicht so viele gucken aber die view time ist ziemlich gut
4 6 8 upgrade installing and enjoying windows 95 45 minuten alter 45 minuten gucken wir uns
nicht hin wobei ich sagen muss leute ich weiß ich bin ich bin richtig krasser boomer was
das angeht aber es ok ok ich muss ich muss mal was zu sagen sekunde weiß ich ob da auch
den sound dabei hat irgendwie also ich muss ich muss jetzt mal was sein an der stelle
aus heutigen gesichtspunkten ist wenn aus 95 halt müll und es war damals stabilitätstechnisch
auch schon müll das muss man ehrlich sagen also mir geht es bei sowas nicht wirklich
um die qualität irgendwie wobei minnows 95 und das kann man glaube ich kaum hoch genug
einschätzen wirklich ein riesen also maßstab gesetzt hat für die zeit damals und auch
für 32 bit betriebssysteme auf besser als me gut dass das stimmt wohl ja wobei me man
muss man muss halt sagen wenn aus 95 war halt wegweisend me war dann halt bloß noch ja
mehr vom alten mit ein bisschen bunt bunteren icons es war nicht wirklich schlechter aber
es war ja auch nichts dolles den sinn von me da hat sie hat sie mir nicht erschlossen
damals hat man lieber windows 2000 verwendet naja aber was ich eigentlich sagen wollte
sollte sagen wollte also mir geht es jetzt überhaupt nicht um die qualität aber ich
muss echt sagen wenn ich dieses windows 95 setup sehe ja auch auf einem röhren monitor
das erinnert mich schon echt an früher und ich denke da gern dran ich habe bestimmt in
meinem leben wenn aus 95 und winnows 98 mehr installiert als jedes andere betriebssystem
alle übertrieben ich habe winnows 98 und winnows 95 mehr installiert als alle anderen
betriebssysteme zusammen in meinem leben wenn man damals sich getroffen hat und irgendwas
spielen wollte oder sich was angucken wollte und was nicht ging was war das erste was man
gemacht hat windows neu installiert und das schlimme war das hat auch teilweise noch dann
funktioniert also ich habe ich habe winnows gerade winnows 98 habe so oft neu installiert
leute irgendwas nicht funktioniert bem neu installiert irgendwie problem bem neu installiert
immer und ich sehe das winnows setup heute noch gerne das winnows 95 und 98 setup ich
gucke mir das einfach gerne an daran merkt man glaube ich dass ich mittlerweile 38 bin
und dass ich halt 1998 rum war ich halt 14 15 ja 14 bin 84 geboren da merkt man halt
dass es so dies die zeit war wo ich zum ersten mal richtig damit in kontakt gekommen bin
wo ich halt auch selbst viel gemacht habe moment installiert der typ davon disketten
sehe ich das richtig und ist kettenlaufwerk sound das kennen die leute von heute gar nicht
mehr leute wer weiß noch wie sich das sound von allem das kettenlaufwerk anhört 3,5 zoll
nicht 5 zoll das kettenlaufwerk der weiß das doch ja du du du du und wenn man könnte
ich euch noch dran erinnern an die legen die das kennen die wenn man die formatiert hat
man konnte ja man konnte ja das ketten auch formatieren dass es dann so gemacht hat wurde
immer gedacht dass irgendwie gleich fällt ihr das ding durch vibration also bricht
es ab oder so aber das formatiert hat das ist immer fast aus dem rechner gesprungen
das ding ja aber trotzdem ich ich dieses windows 95 setup ich meine ich würde logischer
weise heutzutage auch kein windows 95 mehr verwenden aber ich gucke mir dieses setup
einfach gerne an das erinnert mich irgendwie an an zeiten wo ich mir eigentlich um nichts
außer was ich demnächst basteln am rechner oder spiele oder sonst wie irgendwie groß
gedacht wobei das stimmt ja gar nicht das auch ein bisschen verklärt ich meine ich
bin damals in die schule gegangen und die schule hat mich auch extrem abgefuckt ja aber
erinnert mich irgendwie noch so an an alte zeiten ja und das ist ich guck ich guck es
mir einfach gerne an ich guck mir das windows setup einfach gerne wie lange ich an meine
windows 95 rechner rum gebastelt habe ich habe ja teilweise für nichts und wieder nix
das ding neu installiert weil ich das falsche häkchen im setup gemacht habe oder so dann
statt es einfach nachträglich zu machen habe ich lieber nochmal neu installiert die lautsprecher
sind tatsächlich relativ gute hier damals war die zeit also damals bei lautsprechern
war die kleinsten furzigsten dinger stand dann drauf 2000 watt und so was wo so wo sollen
die eigentlich sein mein heizlüfter hat nicht mal 2000 watt wie wie soll das 200 sorry
nicht 2000 200 200 schwachsinn nicht 2000 200 aber selbst 200 ist komplett unrealistisch
was soll das das pulverisiert die dinger bei 200 watt aber ja das oder wenn noch start
moment windows 5 9 start sound sekunde wusstet ihr eigentlich dass dieser start sound nicht
unter windows entstanden ist jetzt habt ihr es noch mal offiziell gehört
ich weiß boomer modus und so aus ist so ich ich guck es einfach gerne wir können uns das
gucken jetzt mal ganz schnell an einfach um eine runde zu kecken was ich da noch so tut
es gibt ob es sollte das richtig machen es gibt ein gameplay trailer zu battlefield drei
wann ist denn bfz season drei release release date startzeit ja games da erzählt wann ist
das 22 november das ist doch gar nicht mehr so lange hin das ist nächste woche nee okay
gucken wir uns doch mal an wie sieht es job technisch aus habe ich die erste stunde vom
stream nur drüber geredet das game sieht in den trailers deutlich besser aus als das
game sieht in den trailers viel besser aus als es wirklich in game aussieht oder haben
die wirklich an der beleuchtung was gemacht weil die beleuchtung ist einfach total also
viel zu einheitlich und viel zu zu zu zu dumpf in dem in dem game also sieht besser aus
als wirklich in game das rtx kann auch sein das kann sein die wollen ernsthaft erzählen
jetzt jetzt wollen sie mit story anfangen im spiel ernsthaft das ist der neue specialist
der da redet dann ist ich auch egal ok leute wisst ihr was diese diese sorte von zerstörung
ist wahrscheinlich im game drinne und die ist nur im game drinne und exakt an dieser
einen stelle damit man das im trailer zeigen konnte der rest ist wahrscheinlich einfach
nicht zerstörbar mal ganz davon abgesehen guckt mal dahinter ist nichts seht ihr das
hinter den fenstern ist nichts das habe ich ja blöde rumgeklickt wo war es denn jetzt
hier habt ihr es gesehen hinter den fenstern ist nichts das sind fenster oder oder halt
fasade und dahinter ist nix nix einfach nix da ist es hip feier
das ist mal eine map die nach einer map aussieht mit mit durchdachten wegen und so ob das denn
wirklich so sein wird mal gucke mal gucke
ok bei dem gebäude der rest ist wieder offene offene landschaft was ist das nur dass sie
so auf offene landschaft komplett stehen riesengroße offene landschaft ohne was dazwischen
aber es sieht zumindest aus als ist hier ein bisschen deckung auch dazwischen und nicht
nur container und sandsäcke zwar zum größten teil container und sandsäcke aber nicht nur
container und sandsäcke
wie genau stellen die sich vor funktioniert eine bohrinsel die quasi am strand steht
also es hat schon seinen sinn dass eine bohrinsel normalerweise ein bisschen weiter vom land
weg ist weil dort ist das wasser irgendwie ein ein meter zwanzig tief da kannst du stehen
aber keine bohrinsel hin bauen
oh manifest hat jetzt noch mehr container guck mal guck mal noch mehr container auf manifest
new weapons ok ein panzer ein tarnpanzer ein ray gun panzer
new assault achso da ist das peter vom microsoft support ok da sieht man jetzt nicht viel zu
70 70 wie kommen die auf 70 waffen ok die rechnen
wahrscheinlich auch auch alles quasi jede nagelfeile die in portal drin ist auch mit
oder
weil das game hat keine 70 waffen das hat wieviel main waffen wir denn das haben da
wenn es 20 sind 20 24 oder so vielleicht mittlerweile
mittlerweile ist ja schon ein bisschen mehr die haben ja auch copy paste alte sachen wieder
reingemacht aber das ist schon sehr sehr dreist 70 waffen dahin zu schreiben 40 fahrzeuge
ist auch naja hat mit der realität wenig zu tun
aber sonst wieder schön gebatet was seit ewig kein nicht mal gestartet ach wenn es
am 22 mann ist guck mal hier 22 22 nächste woche dienstag ich gehe nächste woche mittwoch
noch einmal nach frankfurt mit dem kollege mittagessen aber ich habe mehr oder weniger
jetzt schon urlaub ich weiß nicht ob ich euch das erzählt habe ja also ich habe hier wieder
den kompletten decemberurlaub so hier und ich hatte noch vier tage resturlaub das heißt
ich habe jetzt die woche noch dabei und die woche noch dabei und die zwei tage die ich
nächste hier schwach sind die woche und hier die woche da die nächste woche müsste ich
theoretisch noch zwei tage arbeiten gehen aber ich habe meinen chef gefragt hat gemeint
die zwei tage darf ich auch home office machen also im prinzip könnte man sagen ich muss
jetzt nicht mehr nach frankfurt ich habe jetzt urlaub aber ich gehe freiwillig 23 noch mal
hin weil ich auf dem kollege vor ende des jahres noch mal was vorteilen gehen wollte
können quasi sagen ab ab ab gestern ab gestern urlaub zumindest urlaub von der bahn aber
am 23 muss ich das noch mal unterbrechen dienstag werde ich noch ein paar sachen übergeben
die gemacht werden müssen die ich nicht mal selbst machen konnte mittwoch sage ich dann
zu allen cu ich bin weg für dieses jahr und ich muss wieder arbeiten dann am dritten
januar und dann ist halt die preisfrage habe ich mich für den neuen job entschieden oder
nicht wenn ich mich für den neuen job entschieden habe dann muss ich hier kündigen beziehungsweise
sicher sein dass die kündigung bis hierhin eingegangen ist also besser besser irgendwann
hier so und dann muss ich noch zwei monate bis hier muss ich noch da bleiben und dann
ein neuer job drei monate als ich das mache mal gucken
die zine oder englische für den sub massive subscriptions oh das hat ganz schön geleckt
der hat ganz schön geleckt hier mach jetzt einfach ich warte noch mal ab ich warte auf
jeden fall ab was bei der zweiten bewerbung noch rauskommt beziehungsweise bei der anderen
bewerbung und was nächste woche beim gespräch da mit meinem aktuellen arbeitgeber rauskommen
wie gesagt ich bin bestechlich in zehn jahren immer noch so ja kann sein aber dafür damit
mehr kohle wenn die da nichts bieten bin ich weg
in
der titel ist schon sehr krasse tibet oder nein genius home hacks also neun
geniale hacks für heimwerker oder sowas
was will er uns denn überhaupt erzählen ich will ich will meine wohnung nicht
nicht nicht streichen egal das gucken wir uns jetzt an
leute achtung genius home hacks auf geht's nach dem video müsst ihr mir sagen
wie genius die wie wirklich genial die sind
machst du nie sommerurlaub oder ne mache ich nicht
war ich nicht
du könntest auch einfach gehen je nachdem was du machst aber es wird doch
überall was gesucht
die würdest du den aktuellen arbeitsmarkt beurteilen die suchen alle
immer noch händenregend nach leuten ja mache ich definitiv gucke ich mir das
an so also genius genius pringles leute ich
habe ewig keine pringles mehr in der hand gehabt gibt es die überhaupt noch
und ich glaube ich habe bestimmt fünf jahre oder zehn jahre keine pringles
dose in der hand gehabt gibt es das überhaupt noch ja gibt es bestimmt noch
aber hat hatte jemand von euch ok erst heute gekauft wie gesagt ich habe ich
hatte ewig kein pringles mehr
tricks that i have used throughout the years to make cleanup in painting as
easy as possible ok auf geht eigentlich interessiert mich das thema null aber ich
will jetzt wissen was die genius hacks sind in der metallbranche ja gut da war
kenne ich mich natürlich nicht mit aus
grabsen peter steve stein macht mach einfach eine fachinformatiker umschulung
easy money easy geld easy job just hold it steady and run that roller up and
down the tape audio das liegt am video dass das audio knackt
das nicht bei mir serious max das war nicht bevor ich das video abgespult habe
gell das liegt am video ich höre das auch knacken das liegt am video der
typ hat irgendeinen irgendeinen wackelkontakt in seinem mikro
the last thing you need is this on your wall if you're like me you hate it when
the lid sticks to the can one way to solve this problem weiss ich nicht ich
streiche selten was please it over the can then you put the lid on top and look
at that it'll cause a barrier and keep it airtight if you do happen to get paint
inside the lid on your can all you got to do is grab a little nail just like
this one and all you have to do is hammer it around the edge probably for
good pops will do it and as you can see it leaves enough of a hole for the paint
to drain out are you sick of paint fumes while you're paying
macht ein loch in deckel
wie kann es sein dass seit fünf jahren keine pringles mehr gekauft das ja ist
so leute war das jetzt genius ich bin mir noch unsicher war das war das genius
schon war das schon genius level was er uns gezeigt hat
do is grab a little bit of vanilla a table spoon will be just another add it to your paint give it a good stir it won't change the color of your paint but it'll take away some of those paint fumes and may even make it smell like this and are you
saddich saddich öhl und so was in so einem fall von ist das eine gute idee kann man
da wirklich öhl rein machen oder oder nah all you gotta do is
diese vanille ist das aller keck alu endlich kann ich das emote mal verwenden
leute ich habe das nur für diesen moment hinzugefügt jetzt alle einmal im chat
keck alu und wo ist es denn keck wie heißt das emote überhaupt keck keck
alu jetzt endlich endlich können das war verwendet
für eine einzige sinnvolle anwendung da hat es jetzt keck alu
ok weiter aber das mit alufolie muss ich sagen ist tatsächlich ganz clever das
hält wenigstens hast du war son 2 schon gespielt ja eine runde solo in quartz ich
habe fünf leute gekillt und dann war es vorbei weil ich gekillt wurde wir haben
sogar den gutluck gewonnen dann hatte ich keinen bock mehr und eigentlich wollte
ich mit ein paar bekannten zusammen spielen vierer sport ist aber hat es
ja nicht ergeben bis jetzt das ist eine coole idee das ist eine gute idee ob das
schon genius level ist bei hingestellt das finde ich eine gute idee
der hat so ein bisschen bob ross style reden oder
genius level leute absolut genius level
was ja warum nicht
bob ross weiß jetzt was man macht jetzt musst du erstmal den devil
wie nennt er das immer leute bob ross kucker
ja oder so was der beat the devil wird er gemacht
so immer noch weiß unten oder genius level leute genius leute ok das reicht
jetzt die tips sind sicherlich gut ist wirklich nicht verkehrt ist ganz drüber
lustig mein alles thema interessiert mich überhaupt gar nicht null was haben
wir denn hier als nächstes 13 dinge von amazon die man unbedingt haben will und
die man unbedingt kaufen sollte möchte will das ist doch bestimmt das doch
bestimmt auch absolutes jebait ja guckt euch mal die bewertung an leute das doch
auch so ein jebait video 13 mal gesponsert 13 ok ok wir geben wir geben
ihm eine chance wir gucken uns die ersten paar sachen an
so ein halo ding ich hatte schon was ok erzählen nein das will man nicht haben
lass mal den lockpicking leuern hat rauf los schwachsinn was ein schwachsinn
alter niemand braucht das niemand das ist ein sponsored video das ist das ist das
ist ein sponsored video 100 pro das ist einfach einfach 13 ding das ist einfach 13 mal gesponsert
das gucke ich mir nicht an jetzt oh man ok was haben wir als nächstes
bernfield einspieler zahlen nicht wirklich konvertier koachs kabel into
powerfull isa net ich überlege gerade wann braucht man das das braucht man
wenn man beispielsweise zwischen zwischen keller und erst im stock zwar
einen fernsehkabel hat also koachs kabel aber kein netzwerkabel gar nicht so
schlecht aber da gibt es doch ist ja mal so das ist jetzt nichts geheimes da gibt
es halt so stinknormale so so medien konverter für die das machen
kennt kennt ihr noch jemand
sagt mir nichts also das einfach irgendwelche konverter das müssen
uns jetzt hier an der stelle nicht ich finde es immer geil wenn sie speedtest machen um
ihre leitung zu testen ist doch bescheuert wenn das ding mit gigabit
singt dann muss ich da auch gigabit rüber machen nicht so ein bisschen getröpfel
in den tröpfel internet da muss schon was ordentlich das bescheuerte test origin ist
tot aber geändert hat sich nichts was origin ist tot wirklich wirklich oder
das ist gebaid origin
echt ist origin ist tot ich habe ich habe über origin immer noch
battleflin 2042 installiert
kann eigentlich gar nicht tot sein
er beginnt warping out origin für ea warum brauchen wir jetzt in ea ab das
bedürfnis genau der gleiche kack wie vorher die ea ok war immer ea ab
so schlecht der gleiche müll wie origin
ea ab
es ist der gleiche müll wie origin jetzt bloß mit dark team anscheinend und
warum braucht man jetzt was neues
ok das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an das video geht auch nicht lang
something big ist happening and is happening now over 21 million users
habe experienced origin der kell hat sich aber auch viel mühe gegeben oder zu
frieden und begeistert zu gucken das haben sie ein paarmal aufgenommen ist
was ea damit vor zehn jahren gemeint hat ist dass origin für die nächsten zehn
jahre die schlechteste gaming plattform sein wird und dann einfach abgedreht
wird um einen neuen launcher zu verwenden man muss bei ea eben gut
zwischen den zeilen lesen können um diese dinge auch direkt zu verstehen
nicht den schuld nein nein das ist unsere schuld wir haben das nur
missverstanden ist origin die schlechteste gaming plattform
ups jetzt gemacht
ist origin die schlechteste gaming plattform
naja von u play bin ich auch nicht von u play von u play bin ich auch nicht
ganz begeistert
ja es ist auf jeden fall schon ganz weit unten
es war ein wunderschöner freitagabend und wir sind gemeinsam auf der vulkan
laden gesessen um ein wochenende voller zocken zu beginnen ist das game was
laufen soll apex alle abends auf steam außer einer
der kommt irgendwie nicht und er kommt sogar nicht mal in origin rein wir fragen
die techniker auf der lan sie kümmern sich drum nach 15 minuten kann die
antwort lan so was machen leute heute noch den geht nicht weil origin gibt es
nicht mehr wie jetzt was was soll heißen origin gibt es nicht mehr naja es ist
tot ea hat es gekillt und jetzt gibt es nur noch die ea ab wie alles warum
braucht man solche launcher das ist ganz einfach zum geld verdienen für den
hersteller nicht dass du noch irgendwie die spiele
besitzt oder so das geht nicht du sollst den geld geben aber nichts
besitzen und auch nichts machen können wenn sie sagen gibt es jetzt nicht mehr
oder kostet jetzt mehr oder anderes modell das ist einfach mehr macht für
den hersteller weniger für dich selbst letztendlich unterm strich geht es ums
geld verdienen es hat nichts mit technischen gründen zu tun du konntest
früher spiele starten ohne launcher du kannst heute spiele starten ohne launcher
du brauchst keinen launcher
aber doch es stimmt sollen wir jetzt böse sein weil in origin nichts davon
stand dass der login einfach nie wieder möglich ist oder sollen wir jetzt
glücklich sein weil der login in origin nie wieder möglich ist und was bitte
muss passieren dass origin jetzt so unter dem radar einfach gekillt wurde
ok also es ist nicht wirklich ein geheimnis gewesen dass origin von der
ea ersetzt werden soll nur die wirkliche durchführung war irgendwie nicht
unglaublich toll kommuniziert das mag jetzt so was das ein aber schon
grafana gesehen sieht so bei ea aus durchführung war irgendwie nicht um
warum hat ea grafana mit dinger da drauf was ist das in zappichs
sind zappichs was bin ich was sehe ich da ist das auf jeden fall in grafana das
erkenne ich das ist auch grafana
unglaublich toll kommuniziert das mag jetzt subjektiv sein aber wenn wir als
hardcore gamer auf einer lan drauf kommen dass origin abgedreht wurde
während sich wer versucht darin einzuloggen und keine ahnung hat warum
es nicht funktioniert und dann auch noch die technik nerds der lan nach googeln
müssen woran das liegt dann ist die schuld wohl eher bei der kommunikation
seitens ea zu suchen auch wenn sie eigentlich schon 2020 gesagt haben dass
es ea desktop app und immerhin werden alle games die über origin installiert
sind auch gleich nicht einfach hätte nicht einfach origin jetzt updaten können
in die ea app anstatt anstatt dass wir jetzt noch mal von hand neu installieren
muss etwas sinnvolles gemacht aber um diesen step zu machen hat es doch ein
wenig lang gedauert sie haben lange an origin festgehalten ohne
irgendeine mühe reinzustecken der ankündigung trailer den hier im intro
schon mal kurz heute war schrott das aufwendigste an dem ganzen die gamer
haben origin fast von tag eins weg getrashed talked und seitdem dauerhaft
gehasst aber warum eigentlich naja direkt zu
beginn war das hat es hat halt keinen sinn gemacht
davor war der kram auf steam und jetzt war der kram in origin das ging mir
damals schon auf den sack und immer weniger sachen diesen steam gab ich
glaube battlefield 4 und sachen haben sie erst released jetzt irgendwie zehn
jahre oder so auf steam nachdem es auf origin rausgekommen ist
ich meine schon seit jahren nicht unbedingt in gutem licht steht weil sie
ihre dinge einfach nicht mehr gut hinbekommen sie sind wie wir wissen sehr
gierig unterwegs seit längerer zeit so war es auch schon beim release von seit
längerer zeit ist gut damit auch nicht alleine deswegen war es schön für gamer
zumindest einen stein in der brandung zu haben der immer solide funktioniert
und mit origin hat er dann halbherzig einen direkten konkurrenten zu steam
rausgebracht warum aber schlechten konkurrenten weniger an steam abgeben
müssten weil leute ja dann direkt in origin die spieler kaufen das ist halt
das ding das ist das gleiche mit mit dem epic store origin und sonst wie was ich
für mich ist steam noch eine ganze ecke mehr als einfach eine seite wo ich games
kaufen kann guckt euch mal an wie viel inhalte es zu
spielen eben auf steam gibt es gibt die offiziellen forren
irgendwelche guides du kannst dir screenshots angucken du kannst dir
bewertungen anschauen du kannst das ordentlich filtern ordentlich sortieren
dass du das kaufen und dass die library haben ist ja wirklich nur ein teil davon
steve genau das team workshop alles mit da ist da ist so viel mehr als einfach
quasi in store wo du sachen ins runterladen kannst drüber steam bekommt
nämlich 30 prozent pro verkauf für das dass dann jeder eine funktionierende
plattform mit community features hat das konnte natürlich nicht ertragen dass
ihr auch nur ein cent woanders hinfließt als in zigarren und caviar fürs
management wir sind uns sicher dass sie auch konkurrenz für willhaben machen
würden um sogar beim resellen von games irgendwie mitzuschneiden wenn es denn
da gebühren gäbe nachdem das geld sicher der einzige grund für den ganzen
machen sie jetzt schon es gibt ja jetzt schon teilweise games die musste dann
initial einmal irgendwas drauf aktivieren und wenn du die verkauft
dann kannst du das nicht das ist alles absicht alles absicht gebraucht markt
mochten die noch nie für die spieler selbst gegeben hat war der start gleich
mal sehr holprig und der hasst ziemlich groß ist ja auch irgendwie verständlich
vor allem wenn man bedenkt dass ea sowieso seit mehreren jahren schon mehr
geld durch microtransactions verdient alles durch den verkauf der spiele
die wissen was das einzige game ist was ich mal gebraucht gekauft habe das
einzige passt mal auf xbox 360 avatar
nein im game
nein nein nein nein nein nicht das herr der elemente das einzige game was ich
gebraucht gekauft habe leute und wisst ihr warum nicht weil ich da so mit den
spielen wollte sondern wie ein gamerscore ihr erinnert euch noch gamerscore also
diese punkte die man anlocken konnte dieses game hatte die einfachsten
gamerscores aller zeiten passt mal auf xbox 360
gamerscore ich habe euch das schon mal gezeigt oder hier 1000 1000 games
gamerscore in einer minute du musstest nichts machen du musstest eine
taste für fünf minuten lang drücken beim start
guck du musstest nichts machen einfach eine taste spam 1000 gamerscore
deswegen das spiel kriegst du heute das spiel kannst du heute glaube ich noch
relativ gut verkaufen wegen den 1000 gamerscore
das bauch
ich meine wo kriegst du heute noch 18 euro von all das gebrauchtes xbox game
die wollen alle gamerscore du musst du musst nix machen du musst du musst da
stehen und nix drücken und du kriegst einfach 1000 gamerscore einfach x
nix machen einfach nur eine taste drücken nicht schlecht ohne scheiß
das sind die einfachsten das sind die einfachsten 1000 gamerscore gewesen
die ich hier komm mal hier anlockt die ich je die ich je hatte
so und am ende am ende hatte halt 1000 gamerscore anlockt das war das
einzige game was ich gebraucht gekauft habe so fertig
next sind verstehen geblieben hier habe ich schon mal gezeigt ja ich weiß
ein bisschen mehr profit müssen wir schon paar sachen schon mehrfach
gezeigt alle ihre freunde noch mal finden und dann damit umgehen dass der
launcher auch noch ziemlich buggy ist ja und natürlich auch einen neuen account
erstellen was sonst natürlich die technisch nicht annähernd so gut
gesichert ist wie bei steam selbstverständlich musst du deine daten
angeben du musst halt für jeden scheiß über alle accounts anlegen du kannst
ja nicht mal aufs klo gehen teilweise ohne den account anzulegen
so weit dass es komplett gekillt wurde aber ist die er wirklich besser die
nachteile sind bisher in wirklichkeit die gleichen wie auch davor die
vorurteile sind nicht vorhanden die versprechungen in den interviews sind
wieder mal exakt die gleichen es soll eine marketing leute der platform sein
die den spielern die bestmöglichen gibt um miteinander vernetzt zu sein aber ein
problem gibt es schon mit der aussage die leute wollen das doch gar nicht die
leute wollen steam benutzen es ist scheinbar nichts weiter als steam mit
umwegen es ist auch nicht mal steam dass diesmal
es ist viel viel schlechter als die die frage die uns immer wieder in den sinn
kommt sieht ich nicht dass es von allen erwünscht ist dass die spiele einfach
auf steam kommen anstatt dass sie ein shit extra programm dafür rausbringen
die antwort ist ganz klar vielleicht in einem interview mit mike blank dem
damaligen senior vice president von ea klingt das ganze nämlich irgendwie
komisch ihr müsst wissen ea hat als origin damals rauskam kurze zeit aufgehört
ihre spiele auf steam rauszubringen ja ziemlich klar dass das eine dumme
entscheidung das weiß ich noch mein dazu einfach dass sie eben ihre
strategie verfolgt haben ja gut das ist ja keine erklärung das würde ich
erwarten strategie strategie das müssen wir doch respektieren ist doch klar
scheinbar die erklärung ist weil man hat man sich erhofft nichts weiter als mehr
leuten das spielen ihre spiele zu ermöglichen ist also ganz klarer schritt
irgendwie am weg zu diesem ziel mal kurz allen zu sagen dass die spiele jetzt
nur noch dort spielbar sind wo sie es wollen um danach zu realisieren dass man
doch scheinbar mehr umsatz macht wenn die spiele weiterhin überall verfügbar
sind er meint übrigens auch er würde nicht so sehr in die vergangenheit sehen
sondern eher in die zukunft auch wenn dieser ja das ist das ist ja nur
wirklich ein typischer typischer management spruch als nächstes erzählt
er noch dass du an seine vision glauben musst und so was in uns allen erweckt
hat ist es nun mal so dass er bei der ersten möglichkeit genug profit zu
machen alle games nur auf die eigene plattform packt noch funktioniert das
eben nicht so gut wie teile deswegs von origin bewiesen haben hoffen wir dass
er diesen schritt niemals schafft und dass auch die er weiterhin nichts weiter
als eine rand erscheinung bleibt warum war aber das killen von origin jetzt
final so und am radar ja das interessiert mich auch wirklich wissen auch
weil und am radar hier recht subjektiv war wir vermuten dass man diesen
fehlschlag einfach nicht zu sehr an die große glocke hängen wollte nur blöd
dann millionen nutzer nicht verstehen wieso der log in plötzlich nicht mehr
funktioniert hat als videospielfirma gestartet die einen sinn für kunst
haben und das sind sie auch heute noch mittlerweile haben sie sich aber auf die
kunst spezialisiert alles zu verkacken also auch hier eigentlich muss
man auch erst mal können aber das kriegen andere auch gut hin so
ist das nicht
verkacken können sie an vielen stellen
was haben wir denn sonst hier noch schönes zu gucken ist auch irgendwas
spannendes noch dabei ein made the world smallest server rack katastrophe namens
meta verse das triggert mich wieder das kann ich mir dann angucken
overwatch 2 is a new low in gaming ist es das
monetarisierungs crap halt ja schlimmer als bei anderen weiß ich nicht ich habe
es nicht gespielt ich habe auch gar keinen großen zug dazu wirklich
overwatch 2 zu auszuprobieren muss ich euch ehrlich sagen ich habe ja
overwatch 1 gegrindet bis zum um kippen aber auf overwatch 2 habe ich keinen
bock
aktuelles game star video
oh ganz ehrlich mir tut es um keine publisher leid nicht mal mehr um blizzard
die haben auch schon so viel verkackt
hat jemand das neue pokemon gespielt nicht ich nicht wie gesagt ich bin kein
großer pokemon fan aber nintendo wird sicherlich auch wieder technisch nur
das absolut mindeste abgeliefert haben bei wobei ist ja nicht nintendo wie
heißen die noch mal game freak genau die werden wahrscheinlich wieder
technisch nur das absolut mindeste abgeliefert haben was man abliefern kann
ohne dass die leute nicht mehr kaufen aber bei pokemon verkauft sich immer
hast du schon mal versucht den tisch hauen was ist automatisch das ist eine
gute idee näher mich nicht
könnte man aber machen ich meine man kriegt ja dann sp 32 an die steuerung
dran sollte kein ding sein müsste recht easy
sein will ich aber nicht dran rumschrauben
pay to win aus der hölle wie das meiste pay to win jetzt reicht es nvidia rtx 40
80 im test lass mich raten ist zu teuer für die leistung die man bekommt
der rente immer ganz gut
weiß nicht ob ich das heute geben kann aber das muss ich mir unbedingt ankommen
wer hat eigentlich angefangen was wer hat eigentlich mit dem plötzlich
angefangen zu überhaupt man könnte alte rechnungen unter linux oder du meinst
alte rechner oder was oder alte rechnungen gibt's morgen wieder auf
wachen stream ja klar heute bin ich nur angekommen weil ich
nichts anderes zu tun hatte ich gedacht habe wir könnten ein bisschen schwätzen
man kann alte rechner unter linux ja auch uneingeschränkt weiter nutzen
performance wunder darf man trotzdem nicht erwarten allein schon aus dem
grund weil man eben zu 90 prozent heute einen browser verwendet und der browser
ist unter linux auch nicht schneller als unter windows eher das gegenteil eher
langsamer also im prinzip kannst du das ja schon
weiterverwenden ich meine zum laufen kriegst du auf dem halbpix aktuellen
rechner alles mögliche aber performance wunder darf man davon nicht erwarten
nur weil er linux drauf ist
das kann man so nicht wirklich sagen ja man könnte vielleicht sagen es ist ein
bisschen leichtgewichtiger aber gerade browser laufen unter windows potenziell
besser als unter linux chain law hat eine frage will er denn wissen wir haben
schon ewig eins geplant aber noch nicht aufgenommen
kentos stream ja dann machen wir open office auf und kompilieren erst mal 30
minuten 30 minuten reicht es um open office oder lipro office zu kompilieren
wahrscheinlich nett oder lipro office dauert wahrscheinlich drei stunden oder
so chrome dauert auch fünf sechs stunden
mit dem neuen pc im december ja dann geht schneller mal gerade was checken
jetzt wenn die alle irgendwelche super krassen pleck friday week deals haben
sind so grad 40 90 was ok immer noch das gleiche aber die dinger scheinen jetzt
wirklich lieferbar zu sein halbwegs
was ist denn mit denen los ist das irgendwie ist es aus platin oder was rock
rock streaks ach die ist over glock ich so dass man das da braucht aber da fack
einfach mal 1300 euro mehr
ich muss mal gucken was ich mir jetzt für eine kauf wahrscheinlich macht es
eh keinen großen unterschied welche man sich holt so tag so tag grafikkarten
hatte ich früher oft die sieht auch sehr stylisch aus irgendwo da
guck mal und ist sie kleiner ist die kleiner als die anderen sind die hat
die wirklich nur 2 he oder hat die auch 3 he okay nicht he ihr wisst was ich
meine es lot slots nacho libri dankeschön 14 monate dankeschön messes
ab
und heute mit kraut schon echter für 1500 euro für den rechner habe ich noch
nie ausgegeben aber es wird zeit neue rechner muss
her du du du du du du du du du die new hyperweiser from rancher
alles was von suze kommt taucht nix
ok mein video habe ich mir jetzt angeguckt excellent habt ihr mein video
von heute schon gesehen leute
aha
du denkst bei 70 prozent nicht los
was ist das an die krems da
das muss uns auch noch irgendwann angucken fünf grunde warum sie scharpe
works ist aber nicht heute kriege ich das muss mich zu sehr konzentrieren bei
eben nichts dabei was gucken will muss auch noch ein paar sachen für morgen
aufheben leute z plus plus größer sie schabt du möchtest da ich noch eine
weile online bleibe da ich was zu erzählen habe oder
weil ihr wisst der chat weiß mittlerweile ganz genau wenn solche
sachen gepostet werden dass da spring ich da spring ich immer drauf an aber
heute keine chance neu ist von der arbeit habe ich auch die erste stunde
drüber schon fast erzählt
sie hashtag video du meinst sie latten zauen also ich bevorzuge sie latten
zauen
in der breitband strategie geht es ja auch um 5g also die bill gates micro
chips kommen leute ob ihr wollt oder nicht
du du du du du du du du du genau
leute ich glaube es reicht ich hatte ja echt nur spontan angeschmissen ich
glaube ich morgen früh wieder wie gehabt gel 9 uhr 30 oder so 8 uhr 30 bis 9 uhr
irgendwann geht es los morgen früh jetzt auf ich gucke jetzt auch ein
bisschen streamen physics dankeschön für den zapp und guck dir mein heutiges
video mal rein wer es noch nicht gesehen hat
das kommt nämlich nicht gut an das guckt keiner ich weiß nicht genau warum
der steht dann so früh auf ich alles klar wir sehen uns bis denn
ich kann auch noch hosten ach nee ich will jetzt nicht gucken
was gut leute ich bin weg bis morgen früh zu